[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] then Google Teton,
hold on. Only thing. Uh
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, so many things that you couldn't sample,
or that would be so mad at the TV yet for now.
This is the builder that I taught for 10 months for 10 [inaudible].
The whole Sen [inaudible] bio on the
[inaudible] [inaudible] and fills the bill until we need to know how I feel.
I came late too late to tell gamma or [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Dave has some bounded, the hell
[inaudible] for Bon and
[inaudible] to contact them at Ghana on Hormel, the spawn stuff,
or the spectrum.
So, uh, the came by
[inaudible] frontier being a meditator ship and have seen Callista
or get behind the legs and bought a house down palace, tall,
building Octomom, Hario,
but not over into special peak was staying updated for morning or
[inaudible]. So you'll freak like some
[inaudible] man, a
[inaudible] or they would have made a knee on the acoustic dog.
And [inaudible] go ahead of,
even in our new home at the hospital bed and sister build numbers or
don't [inaudible].
The IO [inaudible], uh,
off to some, if he can move day, uh, we're done.
[inaudible].
The bird. I dunno, by late now.
[inaudible] that will fulfill good. Not so good. So
[inaudible] so including the full chapter, last of flat saga or
[inaudible] that week
[inaudible] it's still tied or came up
[inaudible] [inaudible] so
[inaudible] at the tide. It's good. A flavor of qual or
[inaudible] or title. It feels full tonic fall at all. She a.
E
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Called Navarro morning. What if they're helpful?
And it's Tito to delve on our house, smell to
men who are now, when I have,
when I think about that envious may about who [inaudible]
or who know your date on that deal or
[inaudible] or [inaudible], or,
or, or about eight of the AltEd the investor,
someone couldn't set that moved in there.
Kimbo. It was [inaudible] and that's an
[inaudible] to spend at least
[inaudible] [inaudible] whatever the
[inaudible] they, the school go, they checked off the Sikh toxin.
Um, [inaudible] extreme. Uh, uh
[inaudible] [inaudible].
I should be had you in inconstant. Well, I will, but until I'm at home,
I have an immense bone [inaudible] so [inaudible] means to the mama,
Papa or Viva,
or stay away without ma based in North Korea or solvent
[inaudible] chick, the Kim
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] snap 12 out if belt still, what? I love still at home,
but so when [inaudible] of, well, it could be by
[inaudible] telephone. [inaudible] I'm not slogan
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and they called,
they [inaudible] sometimes,
eh, they won't be vulnerable, whatever, tack something
[inaudible] and then her [inaudible]
[inaudible]. But whenever handler ship and home,
they felt the family knows the fund from one hand is bound themselves.
We show up in home and handle it after he threw it away.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah, I went [inaudible]. I said
[inaudible] on board and how mine and
[inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible],
that's a play about that. So when I do
[inaudible], [inaudible] a
[inaudible] [inaudible] telephone sort of a first
[inaudible] contact, middle house. Elbit's big. Well,
you have to make a cough mud, the more algebraic stuff.
So it'd be on honey and Hannah, the
[inaudible] book de [inaudible] or,
come on with the bulky.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] never fully commit need, but they've lived with [inaudible].
No, I've ordered all day. [inaudible].
North Sam, Kathy, here for firearm on. And so being a telephone and resource,
what a [inaudible] or get
[inaudible] so we know, okay.
[inaudible] came in for Suleyman whenever suing them, put another belt.
He should've been home or hadn't the bag for the [inaudible] the
house first
[inaudible] but [inaudible] not the point you should've been home.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] all or [inaudible] [inaudible] out or
[inaudible] or the silver helmets on the Cadillacs. So
Soviet Vishal, Vishal, censor,
shoulda been bought to they stared at, uh,
[inaudible] both got a legal team.
[Inaudible] a little belt and a half is Kim.
Really bothered that had been taken care of that.
The hard-nosed makes sense.
If I say now, if we estimate on for the, uh, if the Manitoba,
so Bobby narrate, I go now, then how
[inaudible] Sancta.
[inaudible] some taller and home
[inaudible] [inaudible] after somehow
[inaudible] make it has the twin or
[inaudible] I'm Kim Mohandas hail. So Hennessy. Yeah, I think.
Or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and David Pavegen.
Okay. [inaudible] then Holly's Darnell breaking news.
Uh, but man, and uh, on Holden,
Ms. Tanked for mood
[inaudible] [inaudible] health, I would take out all my [inaudible]. Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] October the farm hold them for more,
but if I have my device, [inaudible].
Totally, we want to put a
[inaudible] on things from Hong Kong it's failed on stance or the
[inaudible] thing, or don't matter unions from health owning home day.
So don't feel clean. Yeah. Well, hold on. We're seeing fav
[inaudible] who would have come down in the morning and over unfold
means failed or,
or the coal got hurt at the sort of house school of man into,
for the hit up a soccer thing.
[Inaudible] me. Yeah. Me. It actually
[inaudible] you [inaudible].
Yeah, man. Hope the play you mean? Or Beenleigh for value at all? Some heat, but
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] or after I had a hand, big
[inaudible] or B two today, Leadville it mattered, but
[inaudible] home [inaudible] so
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] means to the trail mobile telephone on both
and the farm stay at the [inaudible] target.
So right under there. So,
so scalp data to have a helmet posted
[inaudible] men.
[inaudible] [inaudible] they're not tell players to come moving and put it on my
next Monday.
They're different days or both at
the interest for the say behind how the sack do under the house. Stand up.
ECNs father don't be locked. So mess. I don't think my teams, they are now
[inaudible] [inaudible] so don't freak mess.
I don't know how Tom Boston eight and still pass pills saying you get to tell
you it all go [inaudible] then how porcelain? Well, they,
they had, you know, late, late the lead
[inaudible] at one school of Venus.
What if the DT dog top? Why did.
Someone else first thing, dealer police, uh,
[inaudible] moving to my [inaudible]
finned Delmon hall hit that Fino Corp men
[inaudible] or it was going to be full data. Put out the unveiled, artificial,
the elevator, put a corner deduct. Well,
no Hong Kong thumb saw it. Some told a hun,
say
For your photograph a to keep the, a, to evade them.
[inaudible] and non-team my sound
to that.
They then taught we all still want to leave [inaudible] but I may normally
toss. Yeah, they incorporated them Alma,
bane, or it's done about them through the door.
They vote, they vote to a full day with waited.
We buy
[inaudible] money into put a half set
[inaudible] Allah day lava heat.
Um, it turned out, um,
uh, [inaudible] uh,
for stolen [inaudible] [inaudible],
uh, some tasty. So, um, I didn't want to be a pilot,
somebody [inaudible], but I, I believe,
um, uh [inaudible] uh, or
[inaudible] [inaudible] or whatever.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] or Bihar,
but tuna Multa Vaya Del
[inaudible] or defense links.
Meaning Manuel [inaudible] I'll be without Moda.
[inaudible] the ain
[inaudible] I think what the hell? Like some, uh, bill, Hey Latina. No,
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] they be,
but not so [inaudible] then have
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] when had the death of Warsaw for the blade
election. [inaudible].
Wow. Yeah. How did it,
how did it.
Tuck.
The whole huffed
[inaudible] on data hub for
yeah, the whole, you know,
if there's somebody else summer live for then, so you fail
[inaudible] or chancellor medicines for so
they hold those. I feel [inaudible] when the
dare be. Holy fought fondant Stuart VOD.
Hold that the whole thing GOTA for my, yeah.
[Inaudible] I'm going to become out of style.
Can solve it. No.
[Inaudible] and bill womb. Kim to have Elwood some,
some Mo it's avail L bell. Hey sir.
[Inaudible] yeah.
They meet, sit at [inaudible] or
[inaudible] or whatever and nothing yet.
[inaudible].
Yeah.
If top-down [inaudible]
Eden, he done,
he Eden processing more than there is you'd or, or, or
they came.
Yeah, the Holy one Guild. How they burn a CNN
and harness from a six or Garmin or a so
[inaudible] company or handhold,
the two devote all force and blow your factories. Nerdy.
Almost everyone on the Lang urban on the blowers
or they, Oh man, man, man phone routine,
or the volt us within us,
we will have folded until you want to argue with them Hollywood footfall setter,
or they hire you. You have to spell it or wound yeah.
Veil that make it shell. Like.
[Inaudible].
The past Skanska Lake two in Ghana. So [inaudible] divided arms
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] or.
Today.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] a blushed overhang or Ailanthus islands
or the full other tightening a school.
But then they were going to
[inaudible] meant for Vail school, but [inaudible].
That I, they get me out there for, uh, the
[inaudible] [inaudible].
The [inaudible] or the half
[inaudible] or
[inaudible] on the half, man. I'll tell you what
[inaudible] will be. Okay.
But he will have constant factor at the hall in yet this in
how to have outside [inaudible] thing.
[inaudible] [inaudible] no real way at Kim's got templates for not a hundred.
So you play with me
[inaudible] [inaudible] no [inaudible] no. Jen came for the title of baby.
Who's going to be help [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Yeah, absolute they've developed the fees.
She handles some surplus and Tanta for keeping this one's called about mayor
[inaudible] would it be the Oxfam mayor Navi
[inaudible] elbow under [inaudible].
So a sort of, sort of it is at the VAR then, uh,
uh, well, uh, slicked,
some fans per plots defense AltEd no gun leopards and sometimes for Kim
or, uh, yeah,
they by Oxford toothed at SITA [inaudible] or
[inaudible] or [inaudible]
doesn't matter if they say that too.
Hard. Hard to [inaudible].
Yeah, I did clout the hell. Am I not allowed to smoke it?
We allowed to be how it works.
[inaudible] but also you have flavored CAMBA Oak at the
fields to make wounds Keller at wounds can counselor now,
but I'll say I was a very
[inaudible] even Blake. And as soon as there's a spot,
that's the spot they get on to salvo status at the mail for can hold.
So not fantasy also on a tanker. They, this Jewish kid food.
So they force full committee. Okay. For men. But
[inaudible] Michelle like Obama. Okay.
Empathy or the whole myth
[inaudible] [inaudible] bell as a base. I sincerely doubt.
Or may in may [inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible] in specific to depart
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh, and so
[inaudible] the whole, you'll still feel, not
[inaudible] men [inaudible].
I
[inaudible] [inaudible] um, I'll I'll let the
[inaudible] harder. I didn't know.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a song or a school today.
That is a fantastic place to shoot on post some video
script by Placer diagnosis from the Manhattan Institute that the kids now or
[inaudible], or
[inaudible] [inaudible] and a chance to man
[inaudible] dude, stand that up. We'll take that night.
The news from the hallway.
I put my also say on your Shanda young,
that here at the air table,
you'll be the boy Yaddo and still come
[inaudible] a Taylor. Dan's got four kids. They made LOL
coma. They blow money.
Hey [inaudible] um,
so I a title kid, um, or, uh, or
[inaudible] we don't, we don't say [inaudible].
[Inaudible] or no, to have Doug autumn, I go to Toby. You have
[inaudible] or
[inaudible] don't have food in them. So we all stopped that they came to numb.
What time can I,
the phone then scattered Vallejo plan is posted all day long.
Just depending on [inaudible] or Skiva.
He still Kim's under.
[Inaudible].
Y'all told him mango beat.
[inaudible] a lot Johann [inaudible] sort of
[inaudible] they played stick nets.
They're horribly tennis ticking then formed. And her
the older Kim's fist MUN,
some design that then if the build in his finger
was.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] um, w
let us better for the out the fin seal.
Kim [inaudible] hammer,
Victor
[inaudible] would they be there for
[inaudible] for Hannah? Bye.
[Inaudible]. Okay. And I'm [inaudible] yeah,
no, this isn't [inaudible] this girl called
[inaudible] New York packing. Yeah. [inaudible] so,
yeah, come in and have
[inaudible] to both get it to him. What are your most out aim? Fast food.
[inaudible] so my nest and they can steal some who, all who fail or
[inaudible] know when I'm gonna buy two or now what is the full
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah. Nice.
Um, Justin doctrinal today.
[inaudible] awesome. Uh, um, yeah, ducks cut at all.